une figure des gilets jaunes transformer
presque en chef d'orchestre des chants
et de la musique pour se réchauffer en
plein mois d'août
des dizaines de milliers de parisiens
présents dans les plus grandes artères
de la ville une manifestation partie
également de neuilly sur seine avec
plusieurs ponts carte très évocatrice
[Musique]
bah moi je viens pour manifester pour ma
liberté faire du sport tout simplement
on va m'interdire faire du sport pour
moi c'est ma vie c'est essentiel donc
j'ai un juste pour ma liberté je suis
très solidaire avec tous les gens qui
sont dans l'obligation vaccinale parce
que c'est c'est un peu du chantage qu'on
leur fait c'est vraiment forcer la main
aux gens sur des questions qui sont
vraiment très très intime parce que ça
touche à notre corps ça touche médical
etc
une quatrième semaine consécutive à
défiler en plus grand nombre et sous
haute protection des forces de l'ordre
bien en place devant et sur les côtés du
cortège
[Musique]
le mot protection qui fait aujourd'hui
débat une protection notamment
sanitaires et encadré qui ne passe pas
du côté de certains politiques mobilisés
samedi les forces de l'ordre qui sont
exemptés et d'autres comment sapeurs
pompiers qui ne le sont pas on ne peut
pas accepter de montrer son état
sérologique son carnet vaccinal pour
aller prendre un café en terrasse pour
prendre un train pour avoir le droit de
travailler enfin on est ou dont la
capitale mais également dans l'aube
les troyens réunis en nombre devant leur
préfecture leur mairie et dans le centre
ville
on veut le droit de pouvoir choisir si
on veut mourir du président ou pas
contre le passé ni terre ou et contre
une vaccination obligatoire les
sentiments sont partagés dans le sud-est
de la france ils étaient plus de 47000 a
protesté à marseille avec en première
ligne certains personnels soignants
syndiqués
a lyon quelques échauffourées et sept
interpellations sont à noter samedi soir
les autorités ont dénombré 181 18
actions en france des revendications
apportant également dans les
départements d'outre-mer les
guadeloupéens ont fait entendre leur
voix
toute la journée et ce malgré une
interdiction de sortir à dix kilomètres
de chez soi